Tout le monde participe par désir de sauver des vies.
Quand mon propre père a eu un arrêt cardiaque
il y a quelques années, l'un des premiers bénévoles
à arriver au secours de mon père
était un des premiers bénévoles musulmans de l’Est de Jérusalem
qui a été formé pour rejoindre Hatzalah.
Et il a sauvé mon père.
Vous imaginez ce que j'ai ressenti à ce moment-là ?
J'avais 17 ans quand j'ai créé cette organisation.
Jamais je n'aurais imaginé qu'un jour je m'exprimerais à TEDMED.
Je ne savais même pas ce que TEDMED était.
Je ne crois pas que ça existait à l'époque, mais je n'aurais jamais pensé
que ce système allait se répandre
aux quatre coins du monde,
et l'année dernière on s'est installé au Panama et au Brésil.
Tout ce dont j'ai besoin, c'est un partenaire qui soit un peu meshugenah comme moi,
qui soit passionné par le sauvetage, et soit prêt à s'engager.
Je suis justement sur le point d'exporter ce systeme en Inde
avec un ami que j'avais rencontré à Harvard il y a quelque temps.
Et avant que l'on s'installe à Williamsburg,
un Juif hassidique a lancé Hatzalah à Brooklyn,
et aujourd'hui le système est répandu dans toute la communauté juive de New York,
mais aussi en Australie, à Mexico, et dans beaucoup d'autres communautés juives.
Mais ça pourrait se répandre partout.
C'est très facile à mettre en place.
Vous avez bien vu tous les volontaires à New York
qui sont venus sauver des vies au World Trade Centre.
Rien que l'année dernière, on a soigné 207 000 personnes en Israël.
42 000 d'entre elles était en danger de mort.
Et on a fait la différence.
C'est une sorte de flash mob de sauvetage,
et c'est efficace.
Quand je regarde autour de moi,
je vois plein de gens qui seraient prêt à faire le pas,
à faire plusieurs pas en courant pour sauver des gens,
quelle que soit leur identité, quelle que soit leur religion,
quelle que soit leur origine.
On a tous un héros en nous.
Tout ce dont on a besoin, c'est une bonne idée, de la motivation,
et beaucoup de « chutzpah ».
Et avec ça on pourrait sauver des millions de personnes
qui autrement n'auraient pas survécu.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)